we have to admit there's something
insidious and detestable about late
night television the kind of vicious
circle it's hard to realize until you
actually go to a taping and the warm-up
comedian gauges your laugh on a 1 to 10
volume scale and instructs you that
you're only in about a 7 and you need to
keep it up and turn it up for every
little joke you're about to see because
the microphones are way up in the
ceiling and they won't hear you
otherwise if he gets to dawn on you
after about 10 cheerless guffaws that
you came to the taping because you
thought the show was funny and you
thought the show was funny because all
the jokes were followed by laughs and
cheers and the laughs and cheers were
forced to make are what's causing the
audience at home to think the show is
funny and it's why they want to come to
the taping themselves which they do and
they laugh and this cycle begins again
disappointing as this is it's also truly
absurd a self-generating absurdity that
appears normal to us because it's all we
know and if a really smart and
innovative comedian wanted to draw
attention to the normalization of this
absurd American ritual perhaps the first
thing to do would be to grab hold of the
absurdity dial and turn it way up
that's the biggest charge I've ever seen
at Hogwarts I don't think this is the
right
we're gonna keep going with this and
we're gonna see when we hit the
pixelation how are we doing
this is Chris Finch lowly unmarried
looking for love life was passing me by
so I sent off my poor two hobbies and
Age magazine marriage I tried the say
for centuries lovely Japanese girls have
been trained in the art of seasoned men
be lonely no more open destinies dog for
$1 they arranged a meeting for 10 years
the brilliant Craig Ferguson has lit a
fire from within the late-night
talk-show universe systematically
deconstructing all its elements whether
it's the deferential sidekick the live
band or the pre-interview Oh
more than any the pre-interview means
nothing it means nothing is meaningless
the pre-interview is a formality like
wearing a tie or Underpants indeed it
seemed like the biggest enemy to
Ferguson sense of comedy was the very
foundation of late-night-tv structure it
Furguson actively sought out the
unrehearsed the spontaneous he
encouraged the awkward the weird the
difficult today we should start
rehearsin us shed light and recognize
and despise late nights deification of
celebrity and took every opportunity to
mock us for buying into him it's a short
time on this planet man it's a date and
then a - and then another date and we
have the - and I'm like I'm not spending
the whole time talking parking
celebrities now this isn't to say that
hosts like Jimmy found who I do like is
somehow bankrupt because all he does is
pay homage to the format by putting it
in terms Y people of today can
understand it's just that he and
Ferguson sit at opposite ends of the
spectrum or rather Ferguson more than
anyone else willingly places himself
outside the spectrum and his
relationship to late-night is of an
altogether different quality a
revolutionary why Americans not hear
God's words you gonna let the Dragon
Tattoo impede the tension between
Ferguson and late-night was what made
Ferguson so funny
his ability to express contempt for his
position his network his job his
willingness to admit his failures to
dwell on them was for many of us
extremely liberating and that's because
late-night TV is a fantasy a fantasy of
sophistication and charm and fun a
standard to which after enough time we
hold ourselves unwittingly no one knew
this better than Craig Ferguson for 10
[ __ ] awesome [ __ ] weird years he
tried to show us that life bears far
less resemblance to a string of funny
stories than to the long awkward pauses
that exist between
well I I hope we've done is it is maybe
trying to maybe art is a very grand word
but but but what I was trying to do here
and what I think that we've managed to
do here is make something that wasn't
here before I like I like chocolate no
chalk I know
dark chocolate is in but I didn't like
you didn't want this did you you didn't
want a robot with pigs and I'm not
someone who creates of his own mind I'd
milk chocolate